can talk to the church Chancellor Rachel
Reeves who joins us now live thank you
for being with us
um just firstly we're just talking to
the chancellor about the collapse of
Silicon Valley Bank UK How concerned are
you and should we be ready to put
taxpayers money in to try and help job
losses
look of course I am concerned about the
collapse of Silicon Valley Bank because
for startups and Venture Capital if uh
life sciences and Tech businesses at
Silicon Valley Bank is an important
source of finance and I am slightly
concerned about the urgency that you
heard from the chancellor there because
when markets open tomorrow morning a lot
of businesses in the UK are not going to
be clear about how they can pay the
wages of their staff and whether their
deposits of Silicon Valley Bank and
their financing arrangements are still
in place so I would urge the government
to do more than offer warm words but
come forward with a specific plans I
don't know the full exposure I'm not
sure if the government do but they must
by tomorrow morning come up with a plan
to give reassurance to those crucial
parts of our economy me yeah there's
conversations going on as we speak so
I'm sure we'll be hearing more about the
plan to try and solve any difficulties
with Silicon Valley bank as soon as
possible
um I just want to talk a bit about Gary
lineker if I may before we get on to
your economic plan Jeremy Hunt very
careful saying that look BBC
impartiality needs to be respected it'll
be wrong for him to comment but some
would say what's at stake isn't up
impartiality but Independence do you
think that the BBC looks too close to
the party of government
thank you
I found it pretty unedifying spectacle
over the last few days as Tory MPS and
Tory ministers put pressure on the BBC
about Gary lineker and if you compare it
to what happened with Richard Sharp the
chairman of the BBC a few weeks ago when
it was discovered that he had helped
facilitate an 800 000 pound loan for the
Prime Minister Tory MPS and Tory
Minister said nothing to see here that's
totally fine and yet when a football
commentator dares to disagree with the
government and express concerns over one
of their policies they all take to the
airwaves to criticize they say they
believe in free speech when they agree
with what someone says but it's all
about impartiality when they don't so I
think we do need a sense of
proportionality here and I don't think
the Gary line occur should have been
taken off air
at the same time that's not just
conservative MPS who weren't happy with
the tweet and in particular the
comparison with 1930s Germany the
Holocaust Education trust spoke out
against that when I spoke to laborers
Emily Thornbury she said that she
thought Gary Lindner could have gone too
far as well
it's not about whether you agree or
disagree with what he said I wouldn't
have used the language that Gary lineker
used but do I think he should be taken
off TV from doing commentary on the
football no I don't and I think that
that was out of proportion
that there is a crisis of confidence now
in the leadership of the BBC you
mentioned there Richard Sharp who failed
to declare his role in helping to
facilitate a loan to Boris Johnson the
BBC's director General Tim Davey has
apologized to viewers do they need to
consider their positions
the people who I
I fought here
is the ministers who lined up to
criticize Gary lineker putting pressure
on the BBC to take him off uh air
unbelievable
just to jump in because I accept that
there have been conservative MPS and
members of the government who've
criticized the Tweet by Gary lineker but
you've said yourself that you know
you're able to disagree with what he
said there hasn't really been many
members of the government calling for
him to be sacked or come Affair unless
I'm mistaken
well my understanding is well I mean you
just see all the tweets and the letters
being organized by conservative MPS
Sophie they're putting on top
intolerable pressure on the BBC to take
action over uh Gary lineker in fact
they've got more to say about Gary
lineker than they do about the cost of
living crisis about the state of our NHS
about the uh failed Asylum system and
the failure to protect our borders more
to say about Gary lineker than frankly
anything else including all of the
issues affecting all of our constituents
on a day-to-day basis that is the
priority now of the conservative some
culture War but rather than the
interests and the concerns of people in
their day-to-day lives that is just all
wrong well let's talk about some of
those concerns now shall we because it
is budget week you of course have got a
very important role at Shadow Chancellor
as well now you spent a long time trying
to prove that labor can be trusted on
the economy you said you would have iron
clad this discipline you promised I will
never make a spending commitment without
telling you where the money is coming
from you know some labor voters might
think that if they look at the state of
Public Services then actually that's
what you should be looking at doing
rather than trying to outtour the
conservative party on spending
well you saw what happened last year
when the conservatives mini budget
crashed financial markets putting
pensions in Peril and resulting in that
long-term Tory mortgage penalty where
anybody remortgaging this year is
looking at paying thousands of pounds
more a year so I am absolutely
determined that as Chancellor I would
have an iron grip on the public finances
and any announcement that I make about
spending and about priorities will say
where the money's going to come from
that's why for example I've said that
labor would extend the windfall tax on
the huge profits that energy Giants are
making and use that money to keep
people's energy bills low it's why I've
said that labor would get the rid of the
non-dom tax status because if you make
Britain your home you should pay your
taxes here and we would use that money
for one of the biggest ever expansions
of the NHS Workforce and free breakfast
clubs at all primary schools so when I
say that we making something a priority
I will tell you always where the money
is going to come from but it does also
mean that there are some things that a
labor government might not be able to do
as quickly as it wants because of those
constraints but I would never put the
public finances in Peril in the way that
the Tories did just a few months ago
because it is ordinary people and
businesses that pay for the price for
that sort of mess
so if you have an iron grip on the
public finances if keeping borrowing
down is key why is the labor party
proposing to spend 28 billion pounds a
year on the green Prosperity plan
well I Look to what President Biden is
doing in the U.S and the response of the
EU and of Australia and countries around
the world that are determined to get for
their countries a share of the
investment in the industries of the
future and President Biden is turning
the Rust Belt into an electric vehicle
belt he is getting good manufacturing
jobs back to the US and is encouraging
businesses to invest there and Britain
is frankly in the changing rooms across
other countries are in this Global race
and a chancellor has got to know when to
say no but they also know need to know
when to make prudent investments in
things to get growth and productivity
and investment going and that's been a
failure of this government when we are
at the bottom of the league tables on
productivity investment and growth and
it will be ordinary people paying the
price for that if you look for example
Sophia what the office of budget
responsibility say they say that
delaying action on getting to Net Zero
by a decade doubles the cost of getting
there so it is a responsible thing to
invest and to prioritize these jobs and
these industries and that is what I
would do as Chancellor because there are
huge opportunities here to get us out of
this low growth low productivity cycle
that we are in and turbocharge our
economy
you know I'm not arguing against the
importance of investing in climate
change but I just want to put it in
context you know the government spends
just over four billion pounds a year on
child care and you're planning to spend
seven times as much on a green
Prosperity plan which is funded by
borrowing I mean these are important
priorities but how can you say that you
have an ironclad grip on the public
finances oh just as long as you don't
look at these massive spending
commitments that we've made over here
well our commitments for the green
Prosperity plan are all in the context
of Labor's fiscal rules which involve
getting a grip on day-to-day spending
and bringing debt down as a share of GDP
and subject to that we will invest in
the things that get our economy growing
so this is part of Labor's fiscal rules
but it is about prioritizing investment
in these industries of the future as
every other country around the world is
doing and the moment to act is now there
is an urgency here because if we want
those jobs and those investment and
every other country in the world wants
them to we have got to have a serious
plan to invest alongside business
through the national wealth fund that a
labor government would create to ensure
that those jobs and investment come here
to Britain otherwise we'll find in the
future that we're importing all of our
cars because we failed to build the
electric vehicles here that we are
importing gas and electricity because we
failed to invest in green hydrogen that
we're importing steel because we fail to
invest in green still I won't allow that
future for the UK where we fall behind
our competitors we've got to act to get
those jobs and investment here in the UK
that's what businesses are telling me
that is what the obr are saying in terms
of the costs of this investment and
other countries are acting I want to see
the chancellor at in the budget this
week
another key focus on the budget will be
growth economic growth and do you accept
that one easy way of improving that
would be to increase targeted
immigration
well I don't think that the immigration
lever is the answer to every uh problem
our mission of an incoming labor
government is to have the highest
sustained growth with good jobs and
productivity in all parts of the country
and that means seizing the opportunities
in towns and cities across the UK
through our national wealth funds and
our green Prosperity plan through our
reforms to make Britain the best place
to start and grow a business but we've
got to be training people up here in
Britain for those jobs in the industries
of the future it's why we have committed
to reform the apprenticeship Levy which
at the moment has seen the number of
apprentices fall and businesses spur
that spurn the system and why we have
said that we would devolve skills and
employment support to local communities
to ensure that businesses where they are
have the skills they need to succeed so
that would be my priority to making sure
that businesses have the skills they
need and that young people and people
retraining later in life have the
opportunity to take up the jobs that are
available in the UK economy
and just finally it has brexit made us
poorer
well look the deal that the government
got is clearly not working for
businesses and every Economist uh says
and all of the forecasts say that that
deal has made our country uh poorer is
why we have said that one of our
priorities for getting that growth would
be reforming the brexit deal not going
back into the single Market or Customs
Union not bringing back free movement
but practical changes that can help
British businesses export and bring
investment to the UK so a Veterinary
agreement to help our great farming and
fishing industries support for us great
Services sector with a mutual
recognition of professional
qualifications helping our brilliant
creative Industries with better deals
about touring rights for artists UK
participation in Horizon to help our
universities uh succeed and bring in
investment so there are practical
changes that we can make so that we can
ensure our economy grow and that we can
take advantage of the export
opportunities that exist but that the
government's trade and cooperation
agreement is cutting British businesses
out of